foreign
just on my way to Midtown to ask people
Danny boy what's up it's good to see you
it's good to see you why are you in the
subway
I'm on my way can you stop
I'm on my way through New York asking
random people because my wife gaps
arrives tomorrow what are you doing
I always get random people what to do in
New York City you gotta take her how do
I zoom in you gotta take her on the
Staten Island Ferry it's free and if you
go at like six o'clock for the sunset
it'll get like the Red Sky you'll see
the Statue of Liberty Ellis Island and
everything Staten Island Staten Island
Ferry don't hang out in Staten Island
it's not a okay but the ferry good
there's literally no one listening to
your music
[Music]
[Music]
I also just quickly wanted to thank the
sponsor of this video being motion array
which is what I use for every single one
of the animations in my videos and I'll
tell you more about them later
[Music]
the most romantic place to take her for
a date would be at my place with me
I think going into the subway probably
and like looking at the rats and stuff
the New York Public Library has a
Terrace that not many people know about
sugarwood it's uh it's quite the Exotic
Place yeah
why don't you go on a tandem bicycle
[Music]
walk over to Williamsburg Bridge at
night the worse the weather the better
it is and also so I think the parks are
romantic you can be by yourself and
still be in the park and the main thing
is I think to be alone the two of you
and I know my baby since uh
1975. wow wow if you could give me one
piece of advice to be in a successful
relationship a long-term relationship be
very patient and you have to listen to
each other and know that if they get
really angry it'll go away
I have to know that they'll come back
with a pint of ice cream I buy her
cookies I do that awesome I found on
your romantic date I will do
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my little bite
this is a form of Transport for the day
is this
[Music]
behind us yeah rest and daughters is
apparently the best bagels in the
entirety of New York City yummy
please take me home with you
okay apparently it's gonna be an hour
long wait which is ridiculous I got my
ticket so these Bagels better be worth
it
[Music]
we got the bagels
[Music]
mine has like funny little balls salmon
cream cheese gabs cream cheese
[Music]
corn none before you've tape
you don't like the texture in my opinion
this is an exotic Bagel it's pretty good
would you wait an hour for this every
day no
good date success
[Music]
[Music]
elbow
[Music]
this is 456 located in the heart of
Chinatown and is supposed to have
incredible Chinese cuisine which is
gabs's Ultimate favorite
I really hope this meets her standards
duck spring rolls deep fried rice two
more spring rolls thank you so much
yummy
[Music]
okay what would you rate that other team
I really like all the people and Dubai
okay
um eight out of ten eight out of 10 for
the people okay we'll leave it at that
[Music]
are you having the Woody or the kitty
I'll take the Woody
all
Steve
how well are we getting your kitties
the Woody doesn't have any jizz on it
wait you said jizz in the context of
this what does that mean
s you want some of that wood
put it back in having too much wood one
day
what is this out of ten ten out of 10.
that's really good it's really funny I
think I can get canceled with the [ __ ]
[Music]
thank you
maybe this is why it's for free look at
all these people
[Music]
how was that well boys wanted to see the
Statue of Liberty and we got to see that
for three so that's really cool that's a
win what did you add it out of ten a
seven out of ten seven seven and a half
seven and a half
now we're on our way to our final date
of the day where we're gonna get really
really hot like way up what you'll see
I think would be about to do is
questionable it's definitely illegal
[Music]
all the way up
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the best view of the whole city
come on this is so cool amazing
oh my gosh
let's see how high it is
oh my
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I know it's like pissing with rain but
yesterday you said that the dates were
10 out of 10.
so does that mean you would consider
moving to New York like it's a full-time
thing
I'd love to come visit you in New York
that's good enough we're getting
somewhere okay say the thing
the motion or anything the thing about
most the program that I use motion array
thank you motion array here's a little
bit more information about motion array
the sponsor of this video motion array
is super simple to use it's the quickest
way to make your content look amazing
you can go from good to great in a
ridiculously short amount of time it's
really easy you can download things in a
second or you can install plugins and
extensions for Premiere After Effects
and Photoshop and get assets even faster
you can try it for free you won't get
access to everything of course but
you'll get hundreds of free assets click
on the link in my description now to Up
Your Story Time by joining motion arrays
over 700 000 premium quality templates
assets stock videos and music also by
clicking the link in my description you
get fifty dollars off your annual
subscription so yeah sign up today if
you go through that brand reads Legend
thank you so much motion Ray is
incredible other than that don't forget
you're awesome brew and
you'll see them next week and
you'll see them next week we'll
see you next week
[Music]